e aí
e como todas as meninas eu tive o diário
com a criança um diariozinho desses que
vem com um mini cadeado para gente
trancar e guardar os segredos só que
geralmente esse cadeado não era muito
confiável ele abre à toa então ainda bem
que ela tinha tantos segredos aos oito
anos de idade foi só um pouco depois aos
13 anos que eu comecei a levar essa
coisa de escrever diário a sério no meu
aniversário de 13 anos eu ganhei do meu
pai dois presentes um caderno bem bonito
e o diário de anne frank meu pai para o
sorvete também escreveu diário a vida
inteira foi ele quem me disse que eu
devia colocar um nome no meu o diário de
anne frank chamava acquire o do meu país
é betty e o meu werber werber hlbr em
homenagem ao personagem do filme se meu
fusca falasse que na verdade se chama
rubi na
nós trazemos ainda não sabia direito
como escrever em pronunciar então quando
eu vi a descobri isso era tarde demais
daí o nome do diário ficou se doer ver
mesmo bom adolescência era normal outros
amigos e amigas também escreverem diário
ou então se expressarem no papel de
outra forma para você fazendo música
poesia enfim só que na vida adulta cada
vez eu acho mais difícil encontrar
alguém que escreva sem um motivo assim
muito forte né que não seja
profissionalmente por que será que as
pessoas param
e eu nunca consegui entender uma vez eu
vi um psicanalista dizer que o
consultório dele era um lugar onde as
pessoas que não precisavam temer onde
elas podiam ter certeza de que não
seriam julgadas eu acredito nisso eu
acredito muito na psicanálise mas sabe
quem eu acho que realmente nunca vai nos
julgar acquire e a bete e o herberth ou
seja os nossos diários ou pelo menos o
papel o papel ele aceita todos os nossos
segredos as nossas contradições as
nossas complexidades
é por isso que tantos anos depois
daquele meu aniversário de 13 anos eu
continuo escrevendo o gente eu escrevo
tanto profissionalmente quanto por hobby
eu escrevo livros escreveu o artigo se
inscreva orações escreva o diário ainda
quando a quarentena começou aqui em são
paulo a minha mãe que mora em bh me
ligou preocupada perguntando assim se eu
ainda tinha eu tinha cadernos o
suficiente para passar pelo tempo do
isolamento social a mãe das minhas
amigas também ligaram né as mães as
minhas amigas também ligaram para elas e
perguntaram se elas tinham sei lá o
pacote de macarrão o papel higiênico o
suficiente em casa mas a minha mãe me
conhecendo sabia que eu precisar de
muito papel para escrever e é verdade
desde março eu tenho escrito muito até
escrito como nunca eu sei que às vezes
parece né que o tempo parou se a semana
são todas iguais mas na verdade
eu já também está escrita me mostre o
contrário não existem dois dias iguais
né a gente pode perceber que mesmo dia
mas sem novidade do mundo sempre tem
assunto porque o nosso mundo interior é
tão vasto a gente não precisa passar por
uma experiência radical para poder ter o
que escrever porém vamos ser sinceros
negócio estamos passando por uma
experiência radical a quarentena é uma
experiência radical e ela traz muitos
novos assuntos sobre os quais a gente
pode falar pensar escrever
o primeiro de tudo sei lá o cancelamento
das olimpíadas do japão que deixou todo
mundo assustado né o cancelamento dos
campeonatos estaduais de futebol aqui no
brasil o fechamento dos aeroportos no
mundo todo o vírus chegando até os
índios os r$600 do auxílio emergencial
que muitas vezes não chegam às pessoas
que mais precisam e ao mesmo tempo tem o
meu mundo interior né reagindo a isso
primeiro a ser lógico que era alguma
coisa muito estranha foi extremamente
absoluta o início da quarentena depois
eu comecei a me familiarizar um pouco
mais conhecia até gostei sabia eu
romantizei a quarentena digamos assim no
começo comecei a pensar poxa vida o
mundo tava muito rápido mesmo estava
precisando de um tempo tava precisando
em desacelerar respirar fundo o caminho
para dentro fica em casa eu escrevi uma
nota falando assim que
e fica em casa você é sua casa no mundo
a melhor casa no mundo mas então eu
parei para pensar aquelas pessoas que
não têm casa ou que mesmo tendo casa e
não são tão poucas assim né as pessoas
que têm casa mas não conseguem se manter
em quarentena então eu me senti culpada
por ter romantizado esse período e eu
fiz bolos e doces para poder sei lá me
distrair eu ficar puxei no home office
eu senti raiva da política eu cortei
minha franja eu senti tristeza pelos
mortos e pelos enlutados por mim eu
achei algumas felicidade no sol que bate
todo dia no meu quarto em um período sem
precedente uma crise sem precedentes eu
também tive uma oscilação de sentimentos
sem precedente de hora em hora meus
sentimentos mudava eram conflitantes às
vezes de minuto em minuto e quem foi que
você sentiu assim né para acompanhar
essa loucura toda que eu tava vendo eu
resolvi fazer um diário mais diferente
daqueles quando era criança e
adolescente o que eu faço normalmente
e eu fiz um diário visual para contar as
minhas histórias da quarentena como
minha mãe sempre deixado com medo né de
não ter papel o suficiente para escrever
a ideia foi inserir então as frases
digitalmente no caderno e foi assim que
eu criei esse projeto vira um projeto eu
coloquei a hashtag e o nome notas
isoladas a vida o que acontece enquanto
você espera a vida voltar ao normal
esperar hoje é terça-feira eu acho
e finalmente nós temos tempo mas que
tempo estranho
em mais um dia de espera menos um dia de
espera sinto saudade de você mas não se
empolgue sinto saudade até do elevador
e amanhã não vou trabalhar de pijama eu
ontem
e agora eu sei como vai fazer
aniversário nas férias da escola agora
estou produtiva agora não estou
produtiva agora estou de novo
tô levando uma vida de cinema o filme de
ficção científica
eu tive um pesadelo com manaus estava
acordada
os indígenas estão em perigo a 500 anos
e todo mundo espera tanto mas alguns
ainda esperam r$600 é
oi me desculpa todas as vezes em que eu
podia ter olhado para você mas eu olhei
para celular
e o carnaval que vai ser rever você
a espera esperança
e me prenderam fiquei livre
o isolamento uma estrela cadente surge
quando o último vizinho apaga a última
luz acesa no prédio da frente faça um
pedido
e eu descobri entre o quarto e a sala
portais e montanhas que nunca chegaria
em outra situação
e hoje já dura dois meses hoje já dura
três meses e ninguém sabe o quanto ainda
falta para um amanhã que as pessoas elas
pareciam se identificar logo no início
assim de cara com aquilo que eu tava
escrevendo ou seja com que eu tava
sentindo teve até uma pessoa que
escreveu assim eu sei exatamente como
você se sente e foi reconfortante porque
eu mesma não sabia exatamente o que
estava acontecendo comigo teve uma
senhora que escreveu assim você colocou
encanto no meu desencanto e esse
comentário guardei assim desse jeito e
precise feliz porque eu achei bem bonito
e eu que pensando sobre isso olha só eu
e outras pessoas estamos reagindo de
forma parecida a uma crise que ninguém
nunca tinha atravessado antes e eu acho
na verdade depois de alguns tipos de
reflexão assim eu fiquei pensando
percebi que isso tem a ver com quando a
gente conta uma história de modo íntimo
pode ser tanto no diário guardado na
gaveta ou não livro que a gente pública
foi por falar da sua vida de forma em
cima que anne frank se tornou tão amada
na época desde então desde que o diário
foi publicado pela primeira vez e até
hoje não foi só por ela refletir sobre a
segunda guerra mundial na qual ela
morreu né ao lado de outros seis milhões
de judeus o que nos comovem homem frank
é a sua capacidade de refletir sobre
família solidão o futuro a menina que
ela que desabrochava que se mostrava
página após página os montejo da mulher
que ela poderia ter sido mas não teve
tempo de ser o seu otimismo
surpreendente
o meu mundo interior da anne frank que
fez com que a gente ficasse apaixonada
por ela que suas palavras fossem tão
fortes né não foi o tempo sombrio apenas
o tempo sobrinha que ela viveu e também
teve a relação dela com diário que é
muito importante aliás identificação
acquire ela não era simplesmente um
caderno a um pedaço de papel ela foi uma
amiga e continua sendo amigo enquanto as
duas puderam ficar juntas muitas vezes
alguém fala comigo nossa eu também
queria escrever na época da minha
adolescência eu escrevi um diário depois
eu parei eu tenho ideia eu tenho um
livro que eu nunca comecei a escrever só
tá dentro da minha cabeça e para todo
mundo em qualquer situação o que eu
tenho a dizer sempre a mesma coisa
escreva escreva porque é um jeito fácil
de se expressar e de se aliviar porque
só você pode escrever as histórias que
você tem para escrever porque bons no
caso de um diário você ainda pode
guardar um amigo e todo mundo pode se
beneficiar
que tipo de amizade né que não cobra
nada que não te julga em nenhum momento
além de todo tem além de tudo tem mais
uma vantagem escrever é barato né quer
dizer você pode a pessoa pode escrever o
maior a maior obra-prima tanto faz um
computador bem caro ou no caderno mais
simples é uma forma muito simples de
expressão o que você vai escrever a
qualidade do seu texto independe do tipo
de suporte a mesma coisa de não poderia
falar um aspirante de escultor né não é
tão fácil a gente ter blocos em casa
blocos de mármore mas a página em branca
aí sempre tem uma por ali por perto
esperando pela gente
olá eu sou apaixonado pelo papel sempre
fui e por isso eu sempre gosto de tentar
influenciar alguém a escrever também eu
sou uma evangelista dos diários digamos
assim já dei vários cadernos de presente
já distribui vários livros com os
diários publicados de pessoas famosas
como a minha amada anne frank e eu
também a fusão são tá águia simone de
povoar
e eu faço isso porque eu acredito
realmente que existe uma mágica
diferente quando você coloca os
pensamentos no papel é meio que os
pensamentos em estado sólido
bom e você aprende a se conectar de um
jeito diferente com você mesma e se
comunica melhor até com os outros eu
acho
e as notas isoladas quem diria me deixar
o assim menos isolada né eu quando tô no
apartamento aqui eu moro aqui perto no
sumaré eu já não me sinto tão sozinha
quando eu começo a ler os comentários
das pessoas e agora mesmo eu tô aqui não
tô mais sozinha tô aqui entre todas
essas pessoas quem diria e também ao
vivo pela internet meu deus isso tem
tudo a ver com quando a gente começa a
escrever você começa e depois da escrita
é que dita ela te leva para lugares que
você nem imagina então resumindo eu
preciso responder repetir se você tem
vontade de escrever
e faça isso apenas comece se você tem
vontade de escrever escreva
é obrigado a